it's uh now our time for our Mi the
a-hole moral quandries which are always
interesting now last week when I
announced that we're doing the the uh
the members block this way and uh I said
that you know there's the there's the
Reddit Forum of miva whole uh questions
which we can still Harvest from and use
but then I I also invited the audience
to submit their own Mida whole uh
situations and I have to say that uh I
am I am impressed it seems that the
audience knew the assignment so we have
some good ones here and these are all
audience submitted
um and we'll uh
we'll start this is from Tim says hi
sweet daddy today was my wife's dad's
side of the family's Christmas gathering
the plan was to eat lunch and exchange
gifts my wife has a stepsister who's a
double dink wad dual income no kids with
two dogs she's a double den quad and
brought her dogs to the party
my first question is did you tell your
uh sister-in-law that that's what she is
that she's a dinkling hey Dink wad
what's up that's that's that's it's not
an insult it's like that's what she is
that's her uh that's her tribe it says I
have two kids ages three and one from
the moment we walked in the door the
dogs were all over my small children
they were in their faces sniffing them
licking them bothering them in response
my kids just wanted to be held by my
wife and I away from the dogs after some
time we finally asked the stepsister to
please put the dogs in the basement
until we left she refused saying that
they were her kids and that we should
let her dog sniff and lick our toddler
children until they lose interest my
wife's stepmother agreed adding that
it's not that big of a deal and scolding
me for being in a bad mood I said to the
stepsister that her dogs are animals not
her children and do not hold a superior
position to my actual real-life human
children my wife burst into tears as
everyone started yelling it got so bad
that we just decided to leave I've had
family drama before but never over
something so remarkably stupid now we're
trying to figure out what to do I'm
considering telling the Stepmom who we
see frequently and took the side of the
stepsister who we rarely see that she
can't see our kids until she apologizes
to us and our children for prioritizing
the dogs over our own children the
Stepmom has a history of trash talking
making comments being judgmental towards
my wife and I so the situation is more
along the lines of straw breaking the
camel's back rather than a first offense
uh are you the a-hole well you already
know my answer to this there's there is
no world in which I would tell you that
you're the a-hole in this situation it
is entirely on the Stepmom the
stepsister and part of this is setting
boundaries which is something that you
know there's there's a certain element
of that that uh is is always necessary
in any marriage when you you know wife
and husband become one you're forming
your own new family
um it's a new family unit and so there's
very often this process of of drawing
lines by setting boundaries
um with what is now the extended family
and it sounds like that's part of what
needs to happen here there's all kinds
of boundaries being crossed I mean not
just bringing the dogs in when they
weren't invited but just the the way
they responded to it you have a a
reasonable request uh which is that your
your kids are upset they don't want to
be like harassed by the dogs
[Music]
and the way they respond to that
reasonable request on your part on their
part is you know shows I think
boundaries being crossed but overall
it's just as you pointed out dogs are
not people
the comfort of
actual people needs to take priority in
some ways the fact that this was you
know her house makes it even worse in
somebody's like I I have I we have a dog
it surprises people to learn we also
have a cat you know neither of these
like I wanted but we have them when we
have people on our house
like if they're not comfortable with the
animals then their comfort takes
priority okay we I and I'm and I'm very
cognizant of that like our cat is is a
is a surprisingly friendly cat and most
cats aren't but this one is like a
little bit too friendly and so maybe
we'll have someone in the house and
they're sitting down and the cat will
just like jump up on their lap without
even asking invading their their uh
their personal space and when I see that
I'm you know we we take the cat we say
like if you don't want the cat there you
can kick her off we'll put her in
another room sometimes it's a cat person
they say oh no I love the cat I want to
have pet the cat and all that
sometimes they're not and so we take the
cat we bring them out of the room
put it in a room somewhere you need to
prioritize the comfort of people and you
can't assume
if you're a dog owner a pet owner that
everyone is comfortable
um having an animal all over them and
that should never be a prerequisite
there should never be like something
that's required of your house guests you
shouldn't require that of them I've been
in these situations myself before going
into someone's house and they've got a
dog the dog's kind of like jumping all
over me it's like are you gonna do I'm
sitting there are you guys gonna do
something about this I I'm in your house
I'm visiting I didn't know I was
entering a zoo like I didn't know this
is petting zoo I wanted to come talk to
you I wanted to have a human to human
interaction this do you see this dog
that is can you do something about this
right now
so you're not there hold not at all make
the New Year all about the new you with
Gen you sell skin care for a limited
time save over 70 off geniusell's most
popular package to take care of all your
skin care needs watch those Fine Lines
forehead wrinkles sagging jawline dark
marks skin redness and even under eye
bags disappear my talent manager Tessa
uses genucel under eye treatment to help
get rid of the bags under her eyes and
she says it works like a charm I ask her
about it every day and she tells me
still working that's the conversation we
have in real life genyourself skin care
can help you turn back the clock and
look 5 10 even 15 years younger it's
made for both women and men say for all
skin types and works for all ages
genucel promises immediate effects and
results that will make you smile or get
100 of your money back right now get gen
yourself customer favorite a deep
firming vitamin C serum it's absolutely
free in every most popular package you
can hydrate your skin while restoring
your natural vibrant glow visit
genyourcell.com news code wall should
check out every order is automatically
upgraded to free shipping that's
genucel.com Welsh genucel.com watch from
Justin says my father had an accident
when I was two years old this accident
damaged his mental capacity everything
up to set accident he could remember
with perfect clarity everything after
was obliterated by short-term memory
failure my mother could not care for he
and I both so my parents were divorced
and she took care of me growing up and
he ended up at a facility that could
take care of him as you can imagine it
was impossible bonding with a father
that couldn't remember anything my
father's side of the family was and
probably still is irritated at me for
not binding or visiting him enough he
died some years ago from cancer I held
this depressing irresponsible Viewpoint
till I ended up in rehab at the age of
35. then a brilliant therapist asked me
to write a letter to him my dead father
of what I missed about him well needless
to say that list ended up being all the
things he wasn't there for this shed
some light for me on this issue but I
still want to ask if I am the a-hole for
everyone else is who knew my father
before his accident or if no one is well
if there's uh you know an a-hole in this
situation I mean and I've I only have
the information that you've given me but
what you're telling me is that your mom
divorced your dad because he had an
accident and suffered a brain injury
divorced him
and then shipped them off to a facility
really struggling with the till death do
us part in sickness and health part of
the of the vows so to me if there is a
if you like an a-hole move and all this
that was it but now as it stands you
know between you and your dad's family
uh there is no a-hole sometimes there
are situations in life that are just
terrible
and there is no
exact right way to handle it there's no
way to handle it that's going to make it
okay or better it's just terrible that's
all it is and so you navigate it's a
miserable situation you navigate the
misery as best you can uh but you can't
feel guilty about it the other thing too
is that you know
uh I never blame children
for a lack of a relationship or a lack
of a bond with a parent that's up to the
parent to form that Bond now in your
dad's case he had this accident he was
in a facility he didn't have full
apparently you know cognitive capacities
so it's not his fault and that relieves
him of the guilt there but it doesn't
mean the guilt goes back to you usually
if there's if a child grows older you
know it moves out of the house it
doesn't really have a bond with the
parent and loses touch with a parent
usually I put the blame on the parent
because it was up to you to form that
Bond you can't put that responsibility
on your child and if you don't do that
when your child is a child there's a
very good chance when they become adults
that they just they're not going to be
interested in like being around you you
had your chance to form that Bond and
you didn't do it it's on you so it
usually goes to the parent in a case
like this it's like it's it's really no
one's fault uh the the guilts and the
the blame goes to no one it's just it's
just what happened
um so I wouldn't feel any guilt about
that and then on your on your father's
family side you know they see the
situation differently they wish that you
had a bond and they're allowed to feel
that way that's perfectly valid as well
from Becca says hey Matt am I the a-hole
for lying to my entire liberal family
about being vaccinated my mother said
she'd refuse to see me or let me see my
98 year old grandmother let's say
hypothetically that I made an
impressively accurate looking fake vax
card to sell this lie
so I'm a liar and a hypothetical
criminal but am I the a-hole and also do
I have to come clean with them like my
Catholic priest told me to they will
without a doubt disown me and never
speak to me again
I certainly would not call you
in a-hole so I'm going to say no you're
not day hole no one has a right to your
medical information
that's the way that I look at it even
your family members no one has a right
to that information that is private
information you don't have a
responsibility to give it to someone and
from you know your Catholic priest you
spoke to he's from the perspective of
it's never okay to lie you told a lie
that's a sin and I understand that
perspective
I tend to look at it a little bit
differently you know I I tend to look at
it as like not everyone has the right to
a certain truth there are truths about
you that not everyone has a right to and
if they're demanding a truth that they
simply don't have the right to then
um I think at the very least your moral
guilt in deceiving them is severely
mitigated at the very least maybe that's
how I would put it the kind of you know
thread the philosophical moral
theological needle here that your moral
guilt is very much mitigated uh at a
minimum because they're demanding
information that they simply don't have
a right to and finally from Clinton my
wife's 40 year old brother has never
grown up and after years of living on
the street and only contacting the
family for money he decided to move back
in with his mom because he didn't want
to live on the street during the winter
after moving in with his mom he finally
got a job my wife and I had to take him
to and from uh work for about eight days
until he got fired for cursing out
another employee
this guy's a real winner this guy is a
winner the money he earned was spent on
booze and his mom told him he wasn't
allowed to drink at her house she asked
me to come over to his sister because he
wouldn't listen so he cussed me out also
he just got another job and asked my
wife to take him to work which I told
her to tell him no because we are not
going out of our way to help him after
he cussed me out in my idea Hole uh once
again no so these are what is I guess
this is four people in a row that I've
absolved of their a-hole guilt so this
has been a surprisingly encouraging
segment and I'm going to say no you're
not the a-hole at all it's a thousand
percent the brother when it comes to
family you should be there to help
family you should be willing to go the
extra mile for family because they are
family but at a certain point you're not
helping them by helping them you know
sometimes the best help for them is to
not help them and this sounds like a guy
that as you said has never grown up he's
this infantilized perpetually adolescent
40 year old and if he has any hope at
the age of 40 of having any kind of like
awake Awakening moment and actually
growing up having a having a very
delayed coming-of-age moment where he
where he has some hope of of living a a
functional productive life if there's
any hope of that and there is hope
because 40 is like you're getting old
but it's not it's you can you can change
even at the age of 40. but that hope I
think hinges at this point on uh on
tough love and he's gonna have to
confront the consequences of his own
decisions and his own actions like
people that are perpetually adolescent
that never grow up one of the reasons
one of the things that puts them in that
state is that they were never forced to
deal with the consequences of their
actions they live in this fantasy world
where consequence is divorced from
action
and the Very definition of tough love
oftentimes is to not be that barrier
between their the consequences of their
actions and the actions to step out of
the way and say nope you're going to
have to I don't like to see this I wish
it didn't have to be this way but you
are going to have to deal with the
consequences of your actions even if
those consequences are quite dire
um and that means that like you end up
on the street because you can't even be
functional in a job for like a week
that's a consequence of Your Action
you're going to have to deal with that
in this case you got another job uh and
now you want a ride to work again but
you're relying on the person that you
just disrespected in this way no it's a
consequence but you're not gonna go help
this guy out your wife's not going to go
help him
after he disrespected her husband
consequence figure out another way to
work walk to work take an Uber like
figure out figure it out I tell my kids
this this is something I have to tell my
kids not like figure out how to get
somewhere because they're they're still
young so it is up to me to bring them
somewhere someplace if they need to go
but there are very often things in life
like the things that are frustrating
them and and they need to be able to
figure out so I'd say to just you got to
figure out you've got to be able to
figure this one out I'm gonna step back
and let you figure it out
and that's what you should do here so
you are not the a-hole he is uh everyone
is absolved
you may all go in peace I'll do it for
today
[Music]